hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to man of madden we're
just getting into the creepy part of
this maybe it started to get at least a
little bit creepier which is awfully
nice hey don't mind I'll be back with
you in a second Julia don't worry I'm
just wandering over here reading
journals and whatnot I think also
standing staring at that book for way
too long
hey a clue I'm not 100% sure what I saw
there so I'm gonna take another look
Dunc okay so I get it I'm not supposed
to let Oliver or Olli or oxen-free smash
Alex's head into the window I get it now
I think - boom I'm not supposed to allow
that to happen
okay it's called in the offing
apparently you're I'm supposed to do
this or something or I have no idea
what's happening here okay whatever I'll
get to it when I get to it and then I
will probably fail because I don't know
how to play this game properly so let's
keep at it then shall we hello where are
you going all right follow me I thought
there might have been something over
here but apparently there was not okay
hey Julie you're just gonna hang back
there all right cool Keep Watch
who's that better than Alex or Brad or
something okay cutscene again I guess it
can't really be a cutscene I think the
gameplay is more of the cutscene in this
you guys are not in a hurry
maybe you should turn off the light now
okay yeah you know that's best to not do
yeah maybe you shouldn't talk either
there what's so smart
all right let's see if I'm gonna have to
do something for this I I want to bet
like either the flashlights gonna start
to roll off why would you just put that
there why would he just put that there
[Music]
uh-huh yeah uh-huh okay and why did he
need a hammer what possible reason did
he need a hammer for he has a good now's
our chance
okay not the not the best way I would
have gone to go down and get it I'm sure
there would have been stairs or
something somewhere that we could have
probably found but apparently not oh my
god wait
[Music]
oh crap
okay
he's got a flashlight better watch out
okay that was weird what what's your
objective here
what what what what he's got a
flashlight what it's not a gun oh he has
a gun though but where did he come I
don't suppose you should keep mom thank
you
she was up well before he's older okay
now if liz has been kidnapped
or maybe not maybe they got a
two-for-one deal
and you guys are no help bash him in the
back of the head
sure diversion pretty much the same as
distraction right what do they keep
passing off the gun like a baton so if
you would just well then what was the
point of any of that what was even the
point Brad is this because I blame
single players either because no one
else is doing anything Brad I got this I
feel like the way that I was supposed to
play this game is to play the couch like
horror movie night version and then I'd
just play all the parts myself I feel
that's really I feel like I'm missing
out on a lot of stuff because they're
just jumping all over the place because
it doesn't seem like anybody can do
anything but here I am all by my
lonesome
la dee dee la dee da anybody you more
stuff that I can read internal
memorandum I forgot I have to hold it
down that's really annoying all right -
all crew area 7c has been converted to a
temporary chapel for the rest of us for
the duration of our voyage all cruel
required to be silent and respectful
when passing near section 7c yes and
corporal or chaplain copied the QM and
AMS I don't know what QM and AMS is but
cool I don't know how that affects
either of us and I don't know why we all
split up again and I also don't know why
you would leave your brother Brad behind
but I guess he's fine when once he once
he plants that boy don't move
come on spook me again come on I want
you to do it oh I want you to spook me
oh come on give me the big spook any day
now
Thanks that's reassuring anything over
here no okay just a convenient place for
a camera angle to change huh what about
over here I think at this point like I
don't know what I need to do to make the
game hate me because it seems like no
matter what I'm doing it seems to be
pretty set on one course what I swear
we've been here before Alex I don't
think we've been here before we gotta
keep moving
yeah I don't think we've been able as if
you know your way around the kitchen
hey babe once we settle down I will be
your personal chef de cuisine is this
really the time to be making lovebird
jokes you know when your brother is in
imminent demise and you seem to have
abandon him you know if I was your
brother I would just think like hello
all right let me just really think about
this what is it you can handle the truth
you're a badass see for yourself
yeah it's gross and also looks
relatively fresh traits updated Julia
decided to be truthful joked reassured
impressed oh I don't know it all that
means all right okay cool
oh I took a screen shot now I've got
that saved in my archive forever
and people are gonna wonder why I took a
picture of gross gross disgusting just
ground to a halt on this one day the
whole ship just stopped functioning yeah
yeah about that cereal on Tuesday that's
not very that's not very impressive
mm-hmm
spoon hmm spoon or knife knife good tool
still sharp we shouldn't be screwing
around right now nice blade could make a
nice severance package for my silence if
you catch my drift we might need it
what I guess you never know we might
have to use it big man on campus
you never know it's a knife of course
get it what do you mean don't get it
what are you stupid get any weapon you
can't you've been kidnapped just no do
you realize that you've been kidnapped
you're on a ghost ship no one seems to
sense the urgency of this I mean even
the kidnappers don't seem to sense the
urgency of this hi you rapscallion kids
breaking out of our prison if we're
focused back in there you take the gun
no you take good no you did good oh I'll
share I sense a memory this way hope I
don't predict the future that don't feel
good okay well cut of your weight didn't
pawn rad said cut of your ship and then
Brad said it's jib and then Conrad was
like don't be it's Conrad Conrad isn't
it wait a minute who is that I seemed
set whoever's doing the stabbing and I
swear this is just the only identifying
feature that I have has boobs so I need
to not give the knife to anybody with
boobs I've just said that's the only
identifying feature that I can see they
are forced what I'm gonna go on so if
anybody with a boob or two boobs has a
knife I will not give them anything let
alone a knife that's why the curator was
drinking because Conrad is the the the
secret Conrad's the one that's doing I
knew it Conrad can't trust him so from
now on I don't trust Conrad pure and
simple Conrad I know trust that's why he
was so flippant with the dudes because
he doesn't want this marriage to happen
oh it all makes it oh boy another
another journal can't wait for this it's
gonna be good
June 18th Wednesday we haven't been at
sea long and I'm sick of the damn food
already that MUC we ate tonight was a
joke the cooks do that best with what I
got for sure but man I'd kill for
something fresh I'd kill for something
fresh first thing I'm doing when we get
home is having me a tall glass of milk
called ice cold milk nothing more
refreshing 19 on a Thursday if we wanted
the US papers we're talking about that
massacre in Philly it's crazy to think
now where are you traveling the world
trying to keep our country safe and
there's people killing each other in the
streets back home I so could use a beer
maybe a nice Miller X in this book after
reading about that home but captain is
issued a ban on booze guess I'll be
counting sheep tonight okay cool good
great glad you wrote all that down
all right Conrad oh I've got my eye on
you I know I saw something he was moving
in the shadows that's probably just rats
that's all it was what I didn't laugh at
you I didn't laugh for you at all
I'm trying to reassure you what it's
just rats you idiot are you stupid
what's wrong with you no you know I said
try to be reassuring cool Jay
a lot of options it's gotta be this way
almost like you know the ship okay no
this isn't working for me what grows
caskets and crappy chapels not my scene
you know what was that
what'd you see supportive it's gross and
it's crappy it's gross gotta get out of
here too sweet
and we gotta find Quinn sweet okay so
can we just get the [ __ ] out then okay
maybe I shouldn't inspect these caskets
with what with zombies and all that
hey we got a name on this guy and what
are they even doing here I don't think
stuck on a ghost ship for all eternity
sounds like a good plan eh who cares
where they're from or where they're
going they're dead and we're not so
let's keep it that way okay five huh
here we go hey what this it's insane
sitting in a human I mean it's it every
human maybe deal with this place that is
some bad mojo
okay leave now leave Leave leave hmm
leave or not leave let's do the not
leaving how about we look at even more
caskets I like the sound of that
yeah look at this one look for a kid or
something let's get out of here yes
maybe that's a little baby Dracula right
there and those are his parents and
they're lying in the dirt from their
native country and they all jump on
Conrad and eat off his face the end hmm
all right one more switch got chains on
his lost in these caskets why would they
be chained and locked well that's one
way to handle relationship
on rad Oh is here to lighten the mood I
don't trust you mr. drinky man so I
won't trust you as far as I could throw
you and I could throw your pretty far
wait no I can throw you not at all far
that's how much I trust you seriously
are you trying to freak me out all right
sure looked like a human net but then
again Brad's face did look very much
alike so maybe I shouldn't be so quick
to judge if only I could walk just the
slightest bit faster but I cannot okay
here we go
sickbay yeah that sounds good that
sounds like a good place to be all right
cool sickbay all right whatever you say
what about Brad where's Brad
guys what about Brad do you seem to be
forgetting about Brad oh come on now I'm
not crazy
Oh am i playing again there's a little
weird hey look it's a body this is no
time to be [ __ ] around I'm serious I
can't take it
that's a shockingly well-preserved body
yes ma keep touching you let's just look
everything under the water I'm not sure
what's going on huh peekaboo I see you
alright fine you wanna play like that I
look at again oh I don't think you could
put a fast one on me okay all right you
know you already passed my little test
day wait hey babe well go look at
something real quick over here Joe hello
secrets goodbye Julia
any medicine we find in here is gonna be
oh I never met him any medicine we find
is gonna be way out of date so let me
just chug whatever is it I can't see
this at all so well there we go aspirin
double D's hey what do you go looking
for a second opinion okay right people
are disappearing left and Ryan there
seems to be nothing uh nothing the
matter with any of this
Conrad's gone because Conrad is going to
betray us and Conrad can do nothing to
make me unaware of his deception anyway
good night sweet prince
anyway um in this room over here no no
babe babe babe hello give him some air
all right
how long am I supposed to stare at this
all right cool goodbye in the middle of
a surgery how I just left him to die hmm
doesn't seem hygienic doesn't seem quite
whoo hey buddy what the hell looks like
he died afraid you can't see that I'm
seeing it right now and it doesn't look
very good but I guess you're right you
cannot unsee that mm-hmm
okay what's this flippy all the way so
this guy had appendicitis which is
pretty routine and then they need out of
a massive heart attack which is not
routine at all
hashtag no no
why was a music being all like that I
mean this guy is going to med school so
he would know how to read an ECG all
right goodbye
everybody in this room Haig behind
goodbyes good talking to you it was
there anything in this cabinet that I
could get maybe some a spy Ryan okay
anyway goodbye goodbye everybody goodbye
you take care of yourself and that sweet
appendix all right now we may go and I'm
not in control
[Music]
where is Conrad this looks familiar on
the head this looks familiar this is the
deep dive
and
I guess it doesn't matter what I would
have said then or not oh hi there you
are again I had almost forgotten about
you no way would I tell you I would not
tell you anything I know I know who this
is
I know Flis hey listen oh come on
don't be like that hey what what'd you
say oh okay you're not even gonna talk
to me anymore
this way oh I'm sorry I have mistaken
hey have I ever told you okay don't want
to make our little conversation huh you
have the most beautiful eyes oh I love
that hat oh hey what sports team is it
do you play sports oh I don't know
something about the shape of her pants
bothers me what was that I'm sorry I
don't know why they look like pants you
would put on a lego person not a
harvestin sure why hmm okay I guess I
won't go through this doorway there we
go
sorry tiny bump excuse me I'm coming
back for another round of the shoving
game nice hook all right come on dude
follow me what do we have here gonna get
you bill you learn you will believe me
alone I'll leave you oh don't push me
I'm just going to tie my shoe over here
I don't have shoes you caught me
red-handed on that one you're too smart
you're smart I'll give you that you're
very smart you're very smart my one
weakness
how could you cut me to my core I don't
know where we're going about I really
hate all the camera angles that make me
stop playing pressing and wondering okay
what was that stop cool if we're playing
red light green light you got to play by
the rules man you got to say to go I
Simon didn't say go Simon didn't say
stop either so I guess I should have
kept walking cool yeah
very peculiar and walking into a wall
the control changes from the camera
angles they're a little I don't think
running exists in this game which is
very bizarre for a horror game hi
Wow Wow buddy Wow
these [ __ ] places cursed hey you
don't know that yet could be something
else going on here
hey you mind you gotta smack this out of
my hands ma Madan Madan ng Madan man of
the mad an military bandwidth list found
a captain's hat with the name ending in
G and then Madan after it oh yeah that
sure is Batarang Madan okay I don't
found a knife and chose to keep it well
that's good
I don't know what to do about that but
sure I really don't know what the whole
compass thing is about
well I've missed out on one apparently
so that's probably probably due to me
not getting away from on the boat so
there's that okay all right sure
whatever you say it's just us
hey don't do that to me
oh come on you're in jump-scare
territory I ain't so easily fooled
also if you guys have seen anything in
the background like a mysterious
mysterious nurse ladies sitting in the
corners oh Christ
oh Christ that guy that guy's probably
still like here with us
I mean you die on a ship your core stays
on the ship
you've no idea what you're talking about
I'm a ship captain who can trust me
even though that incredibly factual
statement is true it's probably an old
wives tale
hey wait you look like the one that
stabbed I don't know what the [ __ ] this
is all about
but we got to keep moving and find Olsen
now okay whatever you say whatever use
yeah a terrified looking corpse it looks
as though they were cowering away from
something when they died interesting I
didn't know that actually this all had
more info on it
okay good no good no I don't know what
that means for us but I have things okay
good I don't know how that's gonna help
me in the game but I have those case got
to fail what man the shots of us walking
down home wait a minute hey come back
here
I'm gonna get you oh I'll show you a
thing or two maybe three oh boy another
one Hey what no but no my mom mo II wait
please please no no you can't do that
too many times you're not strong enough
please I need to look I need to see
please all right so that probably means
I'm gonna come back this way maybe at a
sprinters pace after this guy dies an
unfortunate death
oh yeah here here comes the unfortunate
death oh yeah ding da-ding it's a wall
weird
I'll protect you apparently prisoner of
mine
[Music]
the hell same thing that happened to
that sergeant oh well time to run
blindly into whatever that was hmm it
was a fish you know it was part of the
fortune the fish fortune the fortune of
the fish oh yeah I got a double check
that there was nothing over here well
he's gone now and just like anything
else in this game I don't seem at all
worried about it Oh am I supposed to do
something about that ah no wait no go
back go back do not do this to me again
I swear to God if you do this to me
again and make me not douse way too
close to the boobs there I'm gonna go
back and I'm gonna look okay that was
weird look at this painting what have we
got here and then I'm gonna go back out
I'm gonna get that ramp I'm sorry I'm
sorry what I seem to see here is a
cultist
and as far as I was concerned there
would be no cultists in here I wouldn't
have to do with cultists especially coat
this with a little skull with the horns
on the top of a staff that seems just
like it's so 1940s cultists make so much
sense now that I got that that's great
where was that on my little list of
things Oh God I clicked back oh I'll
never be able to move now don't know why
that's the thing that that is but I'm
gonna go back and I'm gonna get myself a
wrench cuz I need a weapon once I get a
weapon then I'll be able to smack things
and once I'm able to smack things then
they'll be able to do so I gotta get
myself a war
what can I go get myself away I've been
fine I'll go forward then you [ __ ] oh
hi Brad sorry I'm sorry but I'm sorry
okay first of all how did you get past
him wait how did you get here at all I
was trying to catch up to you you know
save you or whatever but then I heard
some crazy [ __ ] and have hiding in the
corner you always take me get out of
this hellhole enough to fresh air where
are you always hiding okay don't say
anything then okay cool
um is this door open now how did you get
how'd you get here not so closed okay um
oh sure whatever yeah Brad know there
were together now ha right let's let's
do this soap I can't let anybody stab
you is the thing I'm gonna do my best to
make sure nobody stabs you at least I'm
able to play a bit more Hey look event
creepy hi Brad get your big muscles over
here big guy
oh sorry are you brought her up Brad
yeah Brad Brad Brad Brad Brad I knew it
was you Brad do your big muscles over
there pride won't you give that give it
a few Yanks I bet you yanked a few
things in your life ha Brad hey we're
back here this is where Joe died wrong
please point Joe Joe no not Joe Joe Oh
Joe wait no Charlie Charlie Oh No or Joe
Joe tie your charlie someone died okay
all right just pick a direction lady
okay I guess I'll go I guess I'll go
around this way then good god
okay thank you who could this be better
charlie
Oh Charlie no all right well Charlie's
dead we all knew that
Charlie you don't look so good anyway
I'm gonna go over here now I guess this
isn't the same place that we were oh oh
is this who is this now boys you it was
you hello nice wait she has boobs
all right I'll risk it well it's a
perfectly good knife well not perfectly
good a little rusty but it's okay okay
bearing okay all right okay
Aaron I got a knife let's find the knife
in the cargo hold all right that's good
I didn't miss one what is that okay she
looks a little stunned okay either way
she found it so that's gotta mean
something that's gotta mean something
real good I got a knife and no one's
gonna take this knife to be able to stab
Brad okay I'm gonna review WASD WASD
WASD wh w w w SSSs DB DD am s s s ad t
is trying to get my muscle memory back
up all right hey how long you gonna be
knelt by those corpses there
mosey on this way found a knife by the
way don't be scared I've got this all
right oh no oh
[Music]
oh okay hey Brad
be careful okay I guess we're Brad now I
don't know how we got separated or else
why you're not calling out to anybody
but but I was just hoping what's
happened in here
something's don't add up some feels a
little fishy why is the power working on
this ship wait hang on
you stabbed me was you
oh I knew it it was you the whole time
oh look at you I brought you mess with
this huh
interesting a bullet but stick that back
in the wounds all right well I didn't
mean to disturb the dead but I gotta
watch out for you I don't trust you yet
do that I don't have a knife
great all these hallways look exactly
alike we're looping we're looping baby
were you why is it shirt different
[Music]
wait what what what why is the shirt
there for it you want to run that by me
why's your shirt different yeah why is
your shirt different huh where's your
shirt it was right there sure different
I don't like that I got a hold up my
skills W hey SD SD w D D D D s SS AAA
ww uh-huh okay all right
why is your shirt different
interesting I'll take this ooh
Alex a bullet and Alex's name on it ha
nerd hmm
hey Flis why is your shirt different you
wanna you want to run that you want to
run that by your run now you want to run
I I love running I'm gonna I'm gonna run
anyways she okay huh these hallways look
exactly the same here
am I not supposed to take the bow you
absolutely what's moving what you're not
gonna question that hey hey listen you
gonna push me you gonna push me you go
put oh no no no one's looking you can
give me exposure keep on moving what
whatever whatever you say oh that's not
good alright okay buddy
hey oh that's good yeah I'll take this
don't worry I'll fix the you right up
okay
[Music]
that's probably not healthy
wait wait wait what's going on what's
going on hey what's going on here hey
what's the big idea
are you sure know what's the big idea
hey what's going on well that was a
little weird was that a ghost of me was
that a me ghost how peculiar wait
where's - bottie or Bolin 'ervix love me
a bullet oh hi Alex
[Music]
[Applause]
hey are you kidding me
are you a are you kidding me I hit a are
you kidding me
I hit a are you kidding me is that that
[ __ ] where it doesn't input my
keyboard cuz it's been doing that that's
not the first time I swear guys
I hit a I did in time way before I was
ready for that one I don't like this I
don't like it I don't like it I don't
like bad controls I mean it controls in
this game are janky as hell but uh dude
I get real pissy when things don't
cooperate with me and when I do
something I wanted to do what I tell it
to do that's the one thing that gets me
more mad than anything else in the world
so don't even try me on this
I pressed hey everything's fine because
he's not dead somehow who's there get
away go get out of here don't even try
it
what's that no I don't wanna I'm gonna
drive down yet what are you crazy when
all these goodies are up here Oh
skeletons well not really skeletons more
like cadavers is some sort of
altercation some sort of altercation
that's not what you just said that's
Easter you ask Sookie kept informed the
radio situations we attempted outgoing
messages the following time and no
response
Oh 1 1001 2001 3000 140 we were able to
pick up indirect messages of traffic
until 101 40 however there has been no
fluke incoming messages track at all
since that time it is possible that a
radio equipment is faulty I am
investigation
I am investigation and expect to be able
to report back to you by oh three
hundred hours private Cooper thanks
private Cooper thank you
hey a ranch
oh thank you very much yeah I'll take
one of those too for me please there we
go
I love the bearing thing found the
spanner above the cargo hold
we both got weapons now hi you're not
supposed to be out here I'm not supposed
to see this
okay cool good glad we all got that
cleared up and now that the the truth
has been revealed with the both of us
we'll be both fine and if alex comes on
knocking again I'll be sure to clobber
him full of sense who I don't
why would I jump in that why would I
have wanted to jump in that I'll put on
the life he vesti and then I'll jump in
that seems like you're in denial there a
bratty boy what could you possibly be in
denial what do you think's going on here
okay so now the question is do I drop
down or do I try the door something
tells me this is a bad idea I don't
think I want to drop down cuz it's uh
straight into water so something tells
me that would be a bad idea for someone
just wander and buy so my gamer instinct
is telling me to go into this door over
here is a much better alternative
because now it's revealing that there's
water there which would be a very bad
thing to jump into so I'm gonna smartly
go through here
nevermind I knew it was the water all
along I had long suspected that I needed
to jump in there I just didn't know when
the opportune time was gonna arise but
now the the stars are in alignment and
my all my all my boxes have been checked
my dots have been ID and my crosses have
been deed I'm going to jump into this
water Julia are you in that bag
there finally someone with good instant
hey man of Maidan was that you man of
mad and my spanner wait you can't just
lose that well I guess I got a ramp now
all right well he's not dead I did see
the man of mad an all right
good great you've done great buddy all
these hallways look so familiar
also I've got my red shirt Wow got
spooked
[Applause]
that's normal
that's normal he's going on here a
little weird oh well back to it hey how
you doing buddy you got a bullet with my
name on it let me just grab that thank
you
uh-huh
look a very peculiar well I'm not gonna
take that huh what is there not good
enough for me all right fine then
whatever you say I rat that's not good
beep I press you can't there
that's not good but nope got dumped got
really ha ha who's got who now me got
you that's not good
okay I'm ready I'm ready I'm ready got
it
got it I got this ha ha not today help
him I mean it's not really him oh hi oh
that's not good all right wait is that
what it meant wait is that what the the
thing the thing is that what the thing
meant that I was supposed to let him get
stabbed is that was that guidance of
what I was supposed to do because that's
really confusing you can see how I would
want to do the opposite thing if that is
what that is supposed to be I like I
knew that wasn't Brad but I wasn't in
that moment being like maybe I shouldn't
or maybe I should know if I need to but
maybe pleasure to save myself but it
didn't seem to be any detriment to me so
because if you look at this
no that's different that's that's a
different thing
that's that's got to be a different
thing that's specifically to Brad okay
so I think I was fine there I think it
was very fine I think I'm very fun fine
I'm all good
I am a 100% okay all right
why is it the blood coming out of that
found that says it's not right or is
just Eddie Berger in a pentagram and
blood fountain hmm a fine vintage 1940
is it ooh
mm-hmm that's no that's something good
and now that's gonna be a gift for all
eternity oh well you know live and learn
I shouldn't have done that
just if you suck in really hard you know
I'm not an expert at the suck I'm more
of a blow type of guy it's not really a
suck okay anyway I must shut up now
before I ruin my reputation forever as a
proper suck you know I don't want people
to know that I'm not not quite capable
what is this the lighthouse the story of
the lighthouse and the guy that was
murdered
know all about the guy that was murdered
with an axe man I got really crazy on
these long what I don't know why another
boy I can't wait to read me a story
now what about the cult mmm Oh
apparently I can read this cabal should
silently assembly and no more than were
fewer than five true individuals of
sound mind spirits
it should number three females and two
males firstborn faces obscured with hood
scissors now it is important to the
sorcerer in the spiritual world beam
rock that before the face review of a
Croma hamari can ritual the threat scare
is performed to went away demon by means
of the Cabal the Pentagon girl shall be
drawn out and each member shall standard
be to the five primary points a lady
born of the Seas shall be rendered
unconscious and playtest at the center
of the vent angle this is from there
that the assembled to recite the
incantation of Ferras sward in hand with
all the exaltation possible as is
written we five stand at the furthermost
point we
yet close entangled the five-star great
power turning 90 degrees to your to
describe the unicursal the pentangle is
Faith's Ward forward and use wrench
turned degrees to describe the oak
curved arrows it'll constitutes the with
reverence turn to face north with
exultation exclaim don't know why I read
that okay there's more I'll kick it it's
miles up there will be more sword for
wood and without sulfation exclaim the
pentangle is sacrifice page 34 of the
Internet has born each member takes a
step in wood and then it's in the stance
of the RAM recite in unison we are one
and so is our Lord also us and this
sacrifice we ask you to cleanse her or
are rid us of the demons that plague us
we spill the life of man in your honor
that we may ourselves worthy of your
thrust with the in can leech should the
fire converge upon the ancestor on each
member should in turn to rid the
unfortunate body of its unclean blood
stole dagger blood three the body should
be transferred to a casket of thick wood
with head accessible by your flock at
any time as a reminder of the evil that
can infect the unwary and the power of
Sorrows to keep all safe and so the
ritual and no longer should spirits a
face devoted may okay there's no more
thank God I wasn't think I was gonna be
able to keep that up and you glad I did
that my voice sure is grateful
okay carrying on from that weirdness to
this weirdness in here you know just
summon a demon inside my own home anyway
I think I saw a premonition about this
some bad it's gonna happen here anyway
this is a woman of the Seas so I think
there might be something bad happening
also light inside head oh it's not there
anymore okay well you know I don't know
if there's any other way to keep your
head on peekaboo oh the Kraken that
can't be good
but that wasn't very helpful
stop Oh keelhaul okay I don't know what
that means I can't seem to make heads or
tails of that but I think that's
probably Julie and Alex needing to save
some I don't think it's like direct
direction of like you need to do X Y Z I
think it's something a bit more obscure
than that I guess I will only know once
I get to the point and then hindsight
will kick in that's not good well let's
walk right in I've seen weirder anyway
let's go up to this casket and see what
the dealio is also I will admit this is
like the longest stretch of actual
gameplay I've had in a long time so this
is getting a little bit a little bit
more fun to play to be perfectly honest
I'm just gonna walk around and
completely ignore that what is that
gross and cool what
that's what happened to Brad Brad
Brad that's Brad he's got the wrench
that's Brad okay I get it now
that makes sense the premonition wasn't
very helpful but I get what that is all
about
don't don't step I'm not gonna stab I
know this is Brad I'm smart god damn it
really really oh that was Brad no what
no that was what but but no that but but
but also I hit the button but I'm not
even like gonna second guess that I hit
the button but that's I'm I expected
that not that
[Music]
number one I hit the button and I'm
really pissed off because I've been I
was I should have just made tried to
make this work a bit better but number
two I know for a fact I know for a fact
that was Brad it's so clear it the
wrench is the same thing the fall is the
same why would that be the way that that
no that was I don't like that that was
the way that that was I disagree
fundamentally with the way that that was
I disagree infinitely about the way that
that was that was dumb and I hate it and
I hate it
by the way I hate it I think it's dumb
and I hate it and I think that it's dumb
and it's stupid I think that it's stupid
I invoked the demon of sorrows and that
was per I know for a fact that was Brad
that was 100% Brad there is no way that
was not Brad so if I am to make sense of
this that is no I can know that that was
Brett and why didn't I get to look at
the casket why did I look at the blood
on the wall and not get to look at the
casket in what world in what way was
that the way that it was and why pray
tell does the game not register my
inputs when I put them in why and what
fresh hell did you think that you can do
these things to me you are an [ __ ]
and if you think that I'm going to take
the [ __ ] from you for me you are
sadly mistaken I will not do that
because I am a persistent douchebag and
if I if this game is as short as it says
it is which seems like it thus might be
they just replay it at this point
because that was [ __ ] and you lie
and you're lying to yourself if you
think I'm gonna take that from you I
don't like that [ __ ]
QuickTime events are [ __ ] I knew
that was Brad it was clear dirt that was
Brad that was clearly Bret and this is
clearly [ __ ]
so I guess huh guess what I'm gonna do
I'm gonna go back but here I am I have
to counteract the [ __ ] so how am I
gonna do it otherwise okay good good
glad we're on the same page so I'll see
you guys in the next episode when I'm
able to rectify the [ __ ] that just
happened to me I don't know how long
it'll take but now that I know the game
and it wasn't that long I guess I
shouldn't be surprised but anyway thanks
for watching and let me know what you
think down the comments below and as
always I'll see you
bye-bye
[Music]